Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube gái Excel bài số
11 định dạng có điều kiện trước khi bắt
đầu bài học ngày hôm nay mình cùng giải
bài tập số 10 hôm trước là định dạng
theo nhá đấy các bạn sẽ mở cái câu hỏi
của bài số 10 lên câu hỏi của mình là gì
bây giờ mình cần định dạng Làm sao để gì
ạ những cái số mà các bạn Nhập vào đây
nó sẽ có tối thiểu là 5 chữ số những cái
số nào mà các bạn Nhập nhỏ mắt xối thì
nó sẽ chèn số 0 ở trước đấy để nó đảm
bảo là luôn luôn có 5 chữ số nhá đấy các
bạn thấy ở đây là gì Ví dụ bạn Nhập 123
đẹp thế nhắc thì nó sẽ chèn hai chữ số 0
ở đây ví dụ các bạn Nhập 2 3 4 hạn thế
Thì nó sẽ chèn hai cái chữ số 0 ở đây
đấy để làm được việc này các bạn làm như
sau nhá đầu tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái
vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn cần định dạng
như vậy nhá Sau đó các bạn ấn canh trước
một để sẽ vào cái cửa sổ có mắt Xem này
thì trong cái thẻ 5m đây này
em chọn cái cát tâm đấy thì ở dưới đây
các bạn xóa cái Zelo đi các bạn sẽ gõ là
gì Các bạn sẽ gõ cho mình 5 số 012345
đợi 5 số 0 ở đây nghĩa là gì Nghĩa là
Cái ô này nó sẽ có tối thiểu là 5 cái
chữ số được hiển thị đúng ạ những cái số
mà nó có ít hơn 5 số thì nó sẽ chèn cái
số không trước đấy gọi thấy cho ở đây nó
có cái mẫu ở đây là diện nếu như mà là
23 thì nó sẽ chèn ba cái chữ số 0 ở trên
này đấy các bạn thường bấm ok nhá Đấy
gọi thấy chưa tất cả các số ở đây nó sẽ
chèn thêm số 0 Để nó đảm bảo là gì ạ Các
cái ở đây nó sẽ có là tối thiểu là 5 chữ
số Ok Giả sử đây mình sẽ nhập lại ba tư
là thế nhá để gặp em tôi gọn thấy nó sẽ
thứ ba cái chữ số 0 ở đâu đấy Nhưng mà
nếu như cái số là các bạn Nhập vào nó có
lớn hơn 5 số nhận ví dụ là diện 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 mạnh thế nhá Đấy thì nó sẽ giữ
nguyên lại Ok như vậy là mình đã xong
cái câu hỏi của bài tập số 10 nhé các
bạn sẽ đóng lại Ok mình sẽ vào bài học
ngày hôm nay là Định
thì các bạn sẽ mở cái file này lên nhá
các bạn chú ý nhé mình sẽ để cái link
tải file thực hành trong phần mô tả thế
giới video tốt nhất là các bạn tải về
các bạn vừa theo dõi và thực hành cùng
mình nhá Nếu như bạn nào mà không biết
cách tải về thì các bạn có thể theo dõi
Cái bài đầu tiên thì trong bài đấy mình
đã hướng dẫn các bạn là cách chi tiết để
các bạn tải về thì mỗi một cái file mà
các bạn tải về Nó là một cái thai nghén
nó chết chứa hai cái file mà file thực
hành và một cái file à câu hỏi để các
bạn làm bài tập về nhà nhá OK thì các
bạn hiểu định dạng có điều kiện nghĩa là
gì ạ Cái định dạng ở đây mà các bạn hay
dùng nhất đấy là các bạn sẽ tô màu hoặc
các bạn có thể là gì ạ Các bạn có thể là
thay đổi phông chữ cỡ chữ các bạn tô đậm
đấy Cái mà mọi người hay dùng nhất là
các bạn sẽ tô màu nhưng mà tô màu là Rịa
tô màu có điều kiện đấy thì tức là chỉ
những cái ôm mà có điều kiện thỏa mãn
thì nó sẽ mới được tô màu nhá Đấy thì
trong bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ làm
cho các bạn là tá
khi mà các bạn hay gặp nhất trong cái
việc mà định dạng có điều kiện nhá Ở mỗi
một cái ví dụ mình đã để một ít những
việc rồi lại rất là thuận lợi cho các
bạn thực hành đầu tiên mình sẽ được vào
cái ví dụ thứ nhất ở cái ví dụ thứ nhất
mình sẽ làm các bạn hai Phần đầu tiên là
các bạn sẽ tô màu mỗi cái phần doanh số
thôi và cái thứ hai là các bạn cho tô
màu cả cái hàng tức là cứ cái doanh số
nào mà nó nhỏ hơn 3 nghìn đấy thì các
bạn sẽ tô màu cả hàng đấy coi đây này
các bạn thấy chứ những cái tháng nào mà
có doanh số nhỏ hơn 3.000 sẽ tô màu cả
hàng đấy Còn đây là gì trong các trường
hợp này là những cái dãy số nào nhắn
3.000 thì nó chỉ Tô màu cái phần danh
chúa thôi đấy để làm việc này thì mình
làm như sau nhá đầu tiên các bạn sẽ copy
này lại các bạn chỉ nháy được phải các
bạn copy các bạn sẽ mở ra đây mình sẽ
làm mới cho các bạn nhá để cậu nhé phải
các bạn sẽ biết Castle mình sẽ biết
value đi đấy bạn sẽ bấm ok Bây giờ mình
sẽ làm các bạn cái phần này nhá đầu tiên
được thì mình sẽ làm cái phần mà tô theo
cái cột doanh số trước thôi thì à
khi bôi đen cái cột doanh số này sau đó
các bạn vào thẻ hôm các bạn vào cái
conditional formatting nhá Thế còn Thúy
nhà ở đây nó sẽ có 1 số cái tùy chọn ở
trên này đấy thì đầu tiên là cái hay
like suru đấy nó sẽ có 1 số Cái gì chọn
mẫu cái glister tức là lớn hơn lesson là
nhỏ hơn bituin ở giữa khi của Tu là bằng
đấy Cái Tech giáp cần tên thế ngàn những
cái ô nào mà chứa cái chuỗi ký tự đến
đây là về ngày tháng Đây là cái giá trị
trùng nhau nhá thì trong cái yêu cầu của
mình là đang là nhỏ hoặc bằng đúng không
Thì trong này nó không có nhỏ hơn hoặc
bằng ở đây nó chỉ là nhỏ hơn thôi đúng
không thì các bạn sẽ thích vào cái
mourou đấy thì nó sẽ tạo ra một cái cửa
sổ mới là cái lưu for Mac dung á thì nó
sẽ lựa chọn cái thứ hai này format only
sell rát còn tên đấy Thì ở đây còn Thúy
Này gái mà mình lựa chọn ở đây là
saverin đây trong các phần này các bạn
đặc biệt chú ý cho mình nhá ở đây mình
đang chọn là nhỏ hoặc bạn đúng không đấy
thì
Ừ cái leger orito tức là diện nhóm học
bằng thì bạn xâm nhập vào đây thì các
bạn sinh nhật số 3 nghìn đấy Bạn thấy ạ
thì nếu như mà cái giá trị nó ngoan
3.000 thì sao thì mình sẽ format Đấy tức
là mình sẽ định dạng đúng ạ Cái trên nhá
Cái này là cái điều kiện rồi đúng không
và cái điều kiện này nếu như mà thỏa mãn
thì các bạn sẽ thích và pho mát đấy tích
và format để mình bị dạng đúng không Thì
ở đây nó sẽ có bốn cái thẻ nạp thẻ
rapper lại chả phone thẻ bơ và thẻ phim
thì thông thường các định dạng mà mọi
người hay dùng nhất thì mọi người chỉ
dùng cái thẻ phim và cái thẻ Phone này
thôi Ví dụ mình chọn cái thẻ sim này nhá
Nếu mình tô màu giống hệt tới đây đi thì
các bạn sẽ chọn cái màu đỏ là màu vàng
đúng không cái phần Phone này là diện
mình sẽ tô đậm lên đấy các bạn xem bấm
ok để cậu thấy đây là cái mẫu mà nó sẽ
hiển thị các bạn nhá các bạn ở ok đấy
Bạn thấy chứ Như vậy là tất cả cái cây
số mà nhỏ hơn 3.000 đã được tô màu rồi
đấy ví dụ ở đây đang là 3.000 8 đúng
không Mình sẽ nhập
ở 8 hạng Thế nhá Đấy gọi enter thì lập
tức nó sẽ tô màu đúng không đây ví dụ
đang làm 1000 đúng không Mình sẽ đổi
thành hạ bốn nhìn lại không Enter thì nó
sẽ không tô màu nữa đấy Đây là cái cách
để mình tô màu theo một cái cột dây số
thôi Bây giờ mình tô màu cả hàng thì
mình làm như thế nào thì đầu tiên các
bạn phải bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn định tô màu đúng không Tức là mình
sẽ Bôi đen cả cái cột là của tháng này
nhá Đấy và cả cái cột cây số nữa sau đó
các bạn vào thẻ hôm các bạn và
conditional formatting thì với cái
trường hợp mà mình tô cả hàng này thì
các bạn phải chọn cái luôn cho mình nhá
Rồi các bạn sẽ đích xuống dưới cuối cùng
Tức là mình sẽ sử dụng các công thức để
mình cảm thấy định dạng đúng không lại
các bạn kéo ra đây thịt các bạn sẽ tích
xuống dưới này để các bạn nhiều công
thức nhá lại còn sẽ bằng là gì ạ Các bạn
sẽ tích vào cái ô doanh số đầu tiên ở
trên cái vùng và các bạn chọn thì lúc
đấy Cái vùng Mình chọn là từ viện từ K6
này đến l17 đúng không thì các bạn sẽ
Ừ Cái ol6 đây là đấy thì bạn chuối nhá
bên này nó sẽ có đô la trước chữ L và
Đôla trước Thứ sáu tôi là nó sẽ cố định
Alo Này đợi thì các bạn sẽ ở ngã 4 cho
mình một hai lần đấy rất là gì ạ Nó sẽ
cố định cái cột lờ đấy thì nghĩa là cái
cột ca này nó sẽ tô màu theo cái cột lờ
đấy còn hiểu ý không ạ Đấy nếu như mà
cái lượt 6 này thì ạ Mà nhỏ hơn hoặc
bằng 3000 nếu như nó nhỏ hoặc bằng 3000
thì các bạn sẽ pho mát chứ mà mình sẽ
định dạng ngọn Đúng không Lấy ví dụ các
bạn Phim này mình sẽ tô màu à vàng này
đi và cái phần phone lại mình sẽ Cún
động nhá lại gọi thì bấm ok ok đấy bọn
đấy nhá như vậy đây là cả hàng rồi lại
ví dụ cái giá trị này đang làm 1000 ở
một đúng không Mình sẽ đổi thành 4.500
hạ thế nhá các bạn enter đây Thì như vậy
là cái hàng này nó sẽ không còn được tô
màu nữa tại vì 4.500 Nó lớn hơn 3.000
đúng không đây ví dụ Cái ô này đang là
diện 3.061 là lớn hơn 3.000 đúng không
Bây giờ mình
cho ví dụ 2.900 Tức là nó nhỏ hơn 3.000
các bạn enter đấy thì như vậy cả cái
hàng tháng 8 này đã được tô màu đấy cảm
thấy không khá là hay ạ Ok mình sẽ sang
cái ví dụ Thứ hai là mình tô màu như ô
mà có doanh số nhỏ hơn ob6 thì các bạn
chú ý nhá Lúc nãy mình tô màu là gì mình
đã cố định cái giá trị 3.000 thì bây giờ
thay vì cái giá trị 3.000 thì mình sẽ
gán vào một cái ô giả sử như cái ôm mình
cần cá là ob6 thì đầu tiên mình sẽ nhập
cái giá trị là 3000đ đây lại tức là nó
sẽ tương ứng với cái ví dụ về sau Nhưng
mà mình sẽ tham chiếu đến cái ô là ob6
chứ không phải là mình sẽ ráng vào cái
giá trị 3.000 đúng ạ Đấy bây giờ để làm
việc này các bạn sẽ copy ra cái vùng dữ
liệu mới về nhà các bạn nhá lại gọi Bôi
đen này các bạn nhớ phải các bạn copy
bây giờ ví dụ xin cấp visa đây nhá các
bạn nhớ được phải này các bạn chọn paste
special Mình sẽ chọn vali đi lấy Gọi sẽ
bấm ok Một là các bạn làm như thế này
nhá Không có thì ví dụ Các bạn có thể
xóa đi Các bạn nhớ thì phải mình đi hết
đi hoặc là gì ạ Bây giờ mình
à Dạ ở đây đi nhá Đấy thì lúc trước là
mình định dạng có điều kiện rồi đúng
không Bây giờ để xóa cái bị dạ có điều
kiện thì rất là đơn giản thôi các bạn sẽ
Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu ở đâu đấy cọ
xem vào các bạn sẽ vào cái phần
conditional formatting họ sẽ chọn Dẹp
cái bạn sẽ chọn cái Crew Tức là mình sẽ
xóa cái Du này đi đúng không để mình sẽ
xóa cái phần mà mình lựa chọn thôi để
còn sơ sinh vào đâu để thì như vậy các
cô đây là không được tô màu nữa đúng
không Bây giờ mình sẽ làm ở đây nhá đầu
tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái doanh số mà
các bạn cần tô màu đúng không ạ Rồi sau
đó các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ hô các bạn và
con disk format tinh thì với cái trường
hợp mà rẻ mình sẽ Tô màu những cái cây
số mà nó nhỏ như một cái ô là ob6 đấy
thì các bạn chọn cái lu này để mình làm
nhá Đấy thì với trường hợp này các bạn
sẽ thích vào cái dưới này để mình nhập
công thức Đúng không các bạn thân bằng
bằng diện các bạn sẽ tích và cái ô doanh
số đầu tiên ở đây này để chắc là cái Ôi
S6 đã chọn xe gì Các bạn thân F4 cho
mình 1 2 3 lần đợi Tức là mình không cố
định đi cả đúng
có quyền áp dụng công thức cho một cái ô
này giống như là cho toàn bộ cái ôm mình
chọn ở dưới này đấy mà gì ạ Mà nhỏ hoặc
bằng thay vì lúc nãy mình nhỏ hơn hoặc
bằng 3000 không thì mình sẽ tích Chọn
vào cái ô này là ob6 thì các bạn Thúy
nhá riêng cái ob6 thì bạn sẽ vẫn để đô
la trước B và trước sáu để Tại vì sao
lại cái ob6 này luôn luôn cố định các
cách tháng khác thì các doanh số đó đều
so sánh với cả ob6 cho nên là cái B6 này
các bạn cứ để nguyên như mình là có đô
la trước B và Đôla chết sáu lúc đấy thì
nếu như mà gì ạ Cái danh số này nhỏ hơn
ob6 thì các bạn sẽ format Thế là mình sẽ
bị giam nó nhá lại cái phone nhá ở đây
là thèm phone không có phải rất sôi động
này cái phần Phi đây ví dụ mình tô màu
này đi Mình không thích mò vàng nữa thì
mình sẽ chọn những màu xanh này chẳng
hạn nha các bạn sẽ bấm ok ok đấy bạn đấy
chứ như vậy là toàn bộ các doanh số nó
nhỏ hơn 3.000 ở đây nó đã được tô màu đó
Bây giờ mình sẽ thay 3.000 và 1.000 hạ
thế các bạn enter thì như vậy
em có cái danh số nào nhỏ 1.000 cả đúng
không Thì nó sẽ không tô màu bây giờ ví
dụ mình tăng lên là diện 2000 đi đó lại
thì những cái ôm mà doanh số nhỏ 2000 nó
đã được tô màu đúng không Bây giờ ví dụ
là 10.000 đợi thì toàn bộ các cô này đều
nhỏ 10.000 bát tô màu đúng không lại Bây
giờ mình sẽ cho về bang Hình như lúc đầu
nhá Đấy bạn thấy không ra làm hai Okay
tiếp theo mình cho tô màu cả hàng đúng
không Chỉ đầu tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
Cái vùng dữ liệu của mình ở đây Đấy tức
là gì từ cái ô G6 đến cái ô diện ố h17
đây này sau đó bạn vào thẻ hô các bạn và
con this new format tinh là các bạn sẽ
chọn cho mình là cái lu đó thì các bạn
sẽ thích vào cái cuối cùng này để các
bạn là công thức nhé mình kéo ra đây lại
thì có ở đây còn sẽ bằng gì ạ bằng các
bạn sẽ tích và cái ô dân số đầu tiên của
cái vùng bình chọn này thì cũng như cái
bài trước rồi các bạn sẽ nhấn bố cho
mình một hai lần đấy tức là rẻ mình sẽ
cố định đô la trước cái cục hát này thôi
đấy tình
ừ giờ này sẽ ăn theo màu của cái cô khác
đúng ạ Nếu như mà h6o diện và nhỏ hoặc
bằng bằng cái ô B6 ở đây đấy thì B6 này
nó phải luôn luôn cố định trước B và
trước sau nhắn tin là các bạn sẽ không
bấm F4 gì ở cái Obi 62 đâu đấy thì nếu
như mà nói nhỏ Nobi 6 thì các bạn sẽ vào
pho mát đúng không lại khi ở đây mình sẽ
tô màu xanh này đi lại cái phone ở đây
mình sẽ tố lượng nhá để các bạn nếu mà
thích cái màu chữ ở đây ví dụ KL mình sẽ
cho màu đỏ đi chẳng hạn thế nhá ở thì
bạn sẽ bấm ok thì đây là cái mẫu mà nó
hiển thị đúng không gọi thì bấm ok đấy
Bạn thấy chứ Thì như vậy toàn bộ các
cách tháng mà nó có doanh thu mà nhỏ hơn
3.000 ở đây thì nó sẽ tô màu cả hàng lại
ví dụ đây mình sẽ đổi thành 5.000 để bạn
thấy cho lúc này rất là nhiều hàng đã
được thì đã được tô màu và được chữ màu
đỏ và tố đậu đúng ạ lại rất là hai ạ Ok
sang ví dụ thứ ba là việc mình sẽ Tô màu
những cái khách hàng mới ở đây nhá
Ừ cái năm 2019 mình có một cái tập khách
hàng là như thế này mình sẽ làm ở đây
cho các bạn hai cái ví dụ một tờ gì ạ
trong cái năm 2020 này mình sẽ kiểm tra
là có những khách hàng nào là khách hàng
mới đúng ạ thì các khách hàng mới dọn
thấy chưa đã được tô màu ở đây là rất là
đẹp ạ còn trong cái ví dụ ở bên này thì
nó sẽ tô màu cả hàng Tức là mình luôn
luôn làm hai cái ví dụ một là các bạn sẽ
Tô màu cái khách hàng mà nó mới thôi và
hay là các bạn sẽ tô màu cả cái của
doanh thu thế nào mình dẫn tô màu toàn
bộ cả cái hàng nhé thì đây là cái kết
quả mình đã làm rồi bây giờ mình sẽ xóa
đi mình làm mới từ đầu nha các bạn sẽ
Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu của các bạn đấy
Sau đó bạn vào cái thẻ hôm này các bạn
vào conditional formatting các bạn chọn
đấy clooney các bạn chọn cái đầu tiên
đây này tức là mình sẽ xóa những cái
định dạng cho những cái xe mà mình Bôi
đen thôi lại các bạn sẽ chọn cái trên
này đấy thì những cái Cell mình Bôi đen
nó sẽ xóa định dạng đi thì đầu tiên nhá
mình sẽ kiểm tra những khách hàng nào là
khách hàng mới đúng không Thì bây giờ để
kiểm tra cái khách hàng nào là cách làm
mới đúng không thì các bạn sử dùng
tin tức là mình sẽ đến gì ạ Mình sẽ đến
trong các tập khách hàng này này có
khách hàng nào mà không nằm trong cái
này không Nếu như mà kết quả là bằng
không thì chứng tỏ là khách hàng mới nhá
Đây mình sẽ làm công thức ở Cái ô này
thế này các bạn sẽ bằng để các bạn có
thể bằng cái hàng cao ít thấy cái vào
cái ghét nhé các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống
gọi tương tác này Ví dụ mình làm cái kz
đi thì đầu tiên là cái vùng điều kiện
đúng không thì con sẽ chọn toàn bộ cái
danh sách các máy khách hàng cũ ở đây
tức là khách hàng của năm 2019 đây này
đấy các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 để cố định nhá
phẩy mình kiểm tra của kẻ khách hàng này
đấy Còn em chơi Đấy tức là lớn như bằng
1 đi thì khách hàng này là khách hàng đã
có của năm 2019 rồi Như vậy khách hàng
này không phải là khách hàng mới đúng
không để họ thích lúc vào đây đây thì
những cái khách hàng nào mà bằng không
này là khách hàng mới lại con thấy cho
thì khá là nhiều khách hàng mà bằng
không đấy Cái cách mình làm mình như vậy
nha Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa đi và mình sẽ
định dạng có điều kiện thì đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng khách hàng của
cái năm mới là năm
Ừ Rồi sau đó thì các bạn vào thẻ hôm các
bạn vào thì con đi xin được format tinh
Các bạn chọn cho mình là lâu rồi này thì
các bạn sẽ thích vào cái cuối cùng để
mình sử dụng công thức nhá Đợi thì mình
sẽ dùng cái hàm cao áp hoặc ASD các bạn
sẽ bằng đấy ạ bằng cao ý ghét đi hả Thế
con sẽ mở ngoặc ra các bạn sẽ chọn một
và các bạn chọn cả 1B hoặc các bạn chọn
toàn bộ khách hàng này không đấy ví dụ
mình Chọn toàn bộ khách hàng này rồi Các
bạn chú ý nhá cái cao ít cái vùng điều
kiện ở đây thì nó có đôla rồi cho các
bạn không sửa thì cả lâu nhé tại vì cái
vùng này luôn là cố định đúng không đấy
phẩy Đến Theo các điều kiện gì đến theo
cái khách hàng đầu tiên ở đây là cái S6
thì các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 cho mình 1 2 3
lần Tức là cái S6 này không có đôla thì
cả đúng không Tại vì mình sẽ áp dụng cho
các cái khách hàng ở dưới này nữa rồi
các bạn đóng mọc lại để xong cái làm cá
tép nhá mà nó bằng điện mà nó bằng 0 tức
là nó không có trong các tàu khách hàng
cũ thì gọi cho phòng mà
ý nghĩa là nó là khách hàng mới đó ví dụ
mình sẽ tô động này khi ở đây mình sẽ
cho cái màu này nhá lại Tùy các bạn Các
bạn thích màu gì thì bọn tôi Ok mình sẽ
ok đấy bọn đấy chứ như vậy lên là gái xe
bốn là khách hàng mới này Đây là khách
hàng mới để những cái khách hàng nào tô
đậm thì nào khách hàng mới đúng không
thấy ví dụ cái gái se1 ở đây các bạn
thích đốt bạn sửa là diện gái xe 4 thả
thấy nha các bạn enter thì lúc này bên
này cái thứ 4 là cái thằng cụ và gái sau
một sẽ là khách hàng mới thì ăn đu này
nhá OK thì tương tự nhá để tô màu toàn
bộ hàng thì các bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái phần
khách hàng và doanh thu đấy các bạn Bôi
đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu khách hàng
và doanh thu sau đó bạn vào thẻ hô các
bạn vào conditional formatting đời Các
bạn sẽ vào cái lu các bạn sẽ tích và cái
cuối cùng để mình sử dụng công thức nha
các bạn thân bằng điện bằng cao USD các
bạn mở ngoặc ra thì bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn
bộ khách hàng cũ và các bạn tất cả các
cột bên này nhá Đấy có tất cả búp bê
cũng được đấy phải gì ạ
đi theo cái khách hàng ở đây là cái
khách hàng đầu tiên hát chào đúng không
riêng ph6 là các bạn phải lớn gấp 4 cho
mình một hai lần các bạn chỉ ấn hai lần
tôi tại vì sao ạ tại vì cái cụ y này là
của doanh thu nó sẽ ăn màu theo cuốn Hát
Này Cho nên nếu như mà các bạn bỏ đô la
trước khi hát mà nó sẽ không đúng lên
nhá đây thì ở đây nó phải là đô la hát
xong là số 6 luôn cái nào nó sẽ cố định
con hát và cột y là ngọn ăn theo màu của
cái quần hát này các bạn xem đó ngược
lại để xong cái hàm kpf nhá Nếu như kết
quả của cái hàm cao f này mà bằng không
thì có bạn xem pho mát để rất là khách
hàng mới đúng không Đây mình cũng tương
tự các bạn vào thẻ phim đây mình sẽ tô
màu ví dụ là màu xanh này đi đấy phone
là mình sẽ tô đậm đi lại gằn phải bấm ok
ok đấy bạn thấy cho như vậy Những khách
hàng mới là nó giống hệt bên này rồi
nhưng mà nó sẽ tô gì cả cái phần doanh
thu ở đây là rất là hai ạ sang ví dụ thứ
tư là việc mình tô màu những khách hàng
cũ tức là này cái này nó lại ngược với
cả cái gì nó lại ngược cả với cái bài số
3 này thì
khi mà hàng cũ đó tô màu thôi lại kiểu
như là cái nhà thân thiết đấy thì với
bài này nhá thì các bạn sẽ làm về nhà
cho mình nhá Đây là bài tập về nhà cho
các bạn nhá Đấy bởi vì cái này nó giống
hệt với cả cái bài số 3 thôi thì cái bài
số 3 thay vì là kpf kia nó bằng không ấy
thì các bạn có thể dán là cave mà lớn
hơn không nó chỉ khác là như thế thôi
nhá thì các bạn sẽ làm cho mình cái này
ở bài tập về nhà nhá Ok mình sẽ sang cái
bài số 5 là Tô màu những ngày cuối tuần
tức là thứ 7 và chủ nhật đấy thì đây là
cái tô theo một ngày đây là tô cả hàng
đấy và nâng cao là thứ Bảy thì tôi một
màu và chủ nhật thì tôi một mặc đấy bạn
thấy cho ví dụ thứ bảy là màu này chủ
nhật là màu này đấy thì đây mình sẽ tô
màu thế nào mình bị dạng theo ba cái ứng
dụng này nhá lại đầu tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi
đen này phải gọn xem vào thì hôm các bạn
vào conditional formatting các bạn sẽ
vào cái clip rudy là các bạn chọn cái
chuyện này tức là mình sẽ bỏ với định
dạng cho những cá Excel mà mình đen đúng
ạ muốn xác định
Ừ nó là thứ bảy hay chủ nhật rất là cuối
tuần thì các bạn sẽ dùng cái hàng
Birthday nhá các bạn Chậm bằng này vui
đây thì các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống này khi
mà cái chữ đây nó được số lượng các bạn
sẽ tát nhá là các bạn chọn cái này trong
cách hàn quốc gia này lại các bạn em
chơi đấy thì ở đây nhá Nó là cái kiểu
ngày tháng các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ hôm
các bạn chân trong cái diện trong cái
Nam bộ Phong ăn này các bạn sẽ chọn cho
mình là Zelo tư lặng cái kết quả của
cách Hàn Quốc Đây này nó bằng 5 đúng
không còn sẽ kết thúc vào đâu đấy thì
các bạn gửi cho mình nhá cái hàng which
đây nó sẽ trả về gì nếu như mà bằng 1
thì nó là chủ nhật còn nếu như mà nó
bằng từ 2 đến 7 thì nó tương ứng là thứ
2 đến thứ 7 cho nên các bạn chỉ cần lưu
ý cho mình nếu như mà chủ nhật thì nó
bằng một còn thứ Bảy thì nó bằng bật đấy
thì như vậy Ở đây mình sẽ dùng cái Hà
mong á cứ làm Mình sẽ định dạng những
cái này này với cái hành bước đây mà nó
bằng bảy gọi bằng 1 thì mới sách tô màu
đúng không Đây đây là mình sẽ dùng cái
Hà mít để mình biểu diễn cho các bạn dễ
hiểu không tức
em lấy thứ cho bạn ở đây rồi nha Bây giờ
mình sẽ Bôi đen cái phần ngày ở đây này
Đấy gọi sẽ vào thì hôm các bạn và con đi
sơ lược marketing Các bạn chọn new rồi
đấy thì ở đây lại sẽ tích vào cái cuối
này để qua sử dụng công thức này các bạn
bằng cho mình ở đây các bạn phải bằng O
đúng không Tại sao lại lo nghĩa là gì
chỉ cần một trong hai cái là chỉ cần nó
bằng thứ bảy chủ nhật thì mình tô màu
đây tại mì điều kiện ở đây là nó yêu cầu
là tô màu ngày cuối tuần mà các bạn
không thể dùng em được các em thì không
bao giờ xảy ra đúng không một ngày thì
không bao giờ là thứ 7 và chủ nhật được
đến một ngày nó chỉ là hoặc là thứ 7
hoặc là chủ nhật hoặc là không là thứ 7
và chủ nhật ấy thì cho nên là đêm mình
phải dùng mong á nhiều bạn rất là hay
nhầm là các bạn cứ hiểu là thứ 7 + chủ
nhật thì bạn dùng em này nhiều khi các
bạn hiểu là như vậy là không đúng đâu
nhé ko là liệu là Quick đây này với đây
cạn của mở ngoặc của cái ông này ở đây
đấy các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 1 2 3 lần đấy các
bạn đóng ngoặc lại mà bằng
khi mà băng 7 đúng không phẩy cái gửi
thức lôgic thứ hai là nhẹ good day của
mở ngoặc vẫn là cái ngày đầu tiên là cái
OVA 5 là các bạn f412 3 lần các bạn đóng
ngoặc lại nó bằng bằng 1 bằng 1 lần chủ
nhật đúng không các bạn xem đóng ngoặc
đơn lại để xong cái Hà ngon này đấy thì
như vậy mình đã xong cái biểu thức điều
kiện ở đây là diệt một là nó là thứ 7
hoặc đó là Chủ Nhật lại nếu như mà nó mà
xảy ra thì bạn sẽ format được đây trong
cái thẻ Phone này mình sẽ tô đậm nhá
phim này Ví dụ mình tô màu xanh này đi
Hãy họ sẽ bấm ok các bạn muốn ok đấy Bạn
thấy chưa Như vậy những cái ngày thứ 7
và chủ nhật đã được tô màu rồi đây ở đây
là có thứ rồi nhắc Cậu đấy giờ thứ bảy
chủ nhật thứ bảy này thì tương tự tô màu
cả hàng nó giống hệt mấy cả tô màu theo
cái cục ngày này thôi Nhưng mà mình sẽ
Bôi đen mà Bôi đen cả cái còn ngày và cổ
thứ rồi đấy đấy các bạn sẽ vào thì hôm
nhá các bạn sẽ bảo con reseller hosting
hệ mình sẽ vào lu bu
a-class tích xuống cuối này để mình nhập
công thức nào ở đây là bằng việc vẫn là
cái Hà Nho thôi mở ngoặc Birthday trước
đây của mở ngoặc nha cọ xát tích là cái
ngày đầu tiên của cái vùng mà mình chọn
này chính là em năm các bạn F4 cho mình
một hai lần thì riêng các trường hợp này
thì làn da cái đôla nó phải trước của e
Thì nghĩa là cái của ép nó ăn màu theo
cái của em này Đấy Wendy của em lắm đúng
không mà mở đóng ngoặc lại mà băng điện
bằng một là chủ nhật đi phẩy hoặc là gì
ạ good day của mở ngoặc là họ sẽ tích và
kệ em này các bạn gấp 412 là đóng ngoặc
đơn lại để xong cái Hàn Quốc đây này mà
bằng bằng 7 đúng không đấy thì họ sẽ
đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong cái Hà mong
này nếu như là gì ạ bằng thứ bảy chủ
nhật thì các bạn format đấy để mình vẫn
là màu xanh thôn ở đây là số động lại
gọn bằng ok ok đấy đoạn rồi chứ Khá là
đẹp được tiếp theo là gì Cái thứ 7 II
ô tô một màu và chủ nhật thì tôi muốn
màu đấy thì thực ra cái này là mình làm
việc mình sẽ làm 2 lần tức là một lần
mình làm cho thứ 7 và một lần mình làm
cho chủ nhật để nó chỉ khác là thế thôi
đầu tiên là diện Ví dụ ở đây mình tô màu
cả hàng đúng không thì các bạn lại Bôi
đen toàn bộ hàng này đấy các bạn sẽ vào
cái thẻ hô các bạn và con đi xâm lược
marketing của mình chọn là News để họ sẽ
tích Bà Rịa có thể tích và cái cuối cùng
để sử dụng công thức nhanh mình chắc
bằng việc riêng trường hợp này các bạn
lại không cần dùng là maurice tại vì ở
đây là gì à Thứ Bảy mới tô một màu và
chủ nhật là tôi một mảnh Tức là mình làm
lại 2 lần đúng không mình chỉ cần rượu
ích wish ray của mở ngoặc các bạn xuất
kích vào điện cái đầu tiên của ông này
là H5 đây này các bạn f412 lần các bạn
đóng ngoặc lại mà bằng đầu tiên Ví dụ
mình làm cho chủ nhật trước nhá mà bằng
1 thì mình sẽ format đấy ví dụ chủ nhật
thì là mình tốt động này phim là mình sẽ
cho cái màu xanh này nhá để chủ nhật thì
là màu xanh các bạn bông ok
Ừ ok đấy còn thấy nhé Như vậy là chủ
nhật là màu xanh tiếp theo mình lại tô
màu cho cái phần thứ bảy nhá Đây cái
vùng dữ liệu của mình vẫn đang được lựa
chọn rồi đúng không các bạn lại vào thì
hôm các bạn và con đi xâm lược marketing
mình yêu rồi đoạn xuống cuối để cho công
thức ở đây mình bằng nhé When they wish
they của mở ngoặc là cái ô thì năm ở đây
lại các bạn f412 lần các bạn đóng hoặc
lạnh bằng điện bằng 7 lúc đấy mình làm
chủ nhật là bằng một từ đúng không Thì
mình làm thứ bảy là bằng 7 thì mình sẽ
format khi này Ví dụ mình cho cái màu
màu vàng đấy đi nhá phone nhá phone mình
chỗ chợ ví dụ cái chữ mình cho màu đỏ đi
lại chủ nhật thì màu đỏ là nghỉ đúng
không thể gọi cho bấm ok đấy bạn đấy chứ
Thì như vậy Thứ 7 ở đây là diện màu vàng
bôi đậm và chữ màu đỏ còn Chủ nhật là
màu xanh và tô đậm nó cũng sẽ rất là hay
sang cái ví dụ thứ sáu là mì tôm vào
những ô mà 5 ngày tới năm khác tức là gì
ạ Giả sử cái yêu cầu của mình ở đây là
mình yêu cầu Tô màu những ngày
à mà nó thuộc cái năm từ năm 2016 đến
năm 2018 thì mình sẽ tô màu thôi đúng
không Thì đầu tiên để tô màu thì mình
phải tách được ngăn ra đúng không thể
loại thực bằng cái Hà Mi ra các bạn đánh
tát nhá thì gọi sẽ tích và cái ô ngày
tháng các bạn enter thì nó sẽ trả về kết
quả năm đúng không Thì nếu như mà để nó
nhận trong năm 2016 đến 2018 thì các bạn
có thể dùng cái hàm em đúng không en của
cái em à diện lớn học bằng 2016 và nhỏ
được bằng 2018 thì mình mới tô màu đúng
không ạ Đấy là cái ý tưởng nhé Bây giờ
mình xóa đi thì đầu tiên mình sẽ Bôi đen
mình sẽ bỏ cái định dạng này chưa đã nhá
Để mình làm từ đầu mà đã chọn và thẻ hôm
các bạn và con reseller hosting mình sẽ
xóa cái Judy mình Mình sẽ chọn cái
clorua này nhá hải quan sẽ chọn cái trên
này mình sẽ xóa những cái định dạng cho
cái ôm trọn thôi Đấy bây giờ bắt đầu
mình làm mới lại từ đầu nhé đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn cần tô màu này các bạn vào thẻ Hôm
con đi sẽ được pho mát tinh Các bạn chọn
newsroom đấy à
anh ở đây bạn sẽ thích và dưới này mình
sử dụng công thức nhá các bạn sẽ bằng là
gì ạ Bây giờ mình phải dùng cái điều
kiện là lại ăn rồi đúng không em nó nằm
trong khoảng mà Thì mình sẽ dùng cái hộp
em em của dì của khách hàng is a kia của
mở ngoặc các bạn rất thích vào cái ô đầu
tiên của cái vùng dữ liệu là C4 các bạn
sẽ nhấn F4 1 2 3 lần là yêu của cái ngày
tháng của oc4 này mà lớn hơn hoặc bằng
điện 2016 đây quạt xuất hiện còn phẩm
cái điều kiện thứ hai là gì ạ là vẫn là
cái hàng bia này thôi còn mở ngoặc ra
vẫn là của Okay bố thí Bạn có thể gọi
trực tiếp là C4 vào đây cũng được nhá
Đấy đóng ngoặc đơn lại mà dịp nhỏ hơn
hoặc bằng 2018 đấy cọ sơn đóng ngoặc đơn
lại đã xong cái hàm em này Đấy Như vậy
là mình đã xong cái biểu thức lôgic là
cái Hà mint rất là những cái ô nào mà
thỏa mãn là việc cái năm của nó trong
cái khoản từ 2016 đến 2018 nhá thì mình
sẽ format Đây Thôn ở đây ví dụ là mình
Tôn
ở giữa màu đỏ đi khi nào mình chọn màu
vàng nhé các bạn nói ok ok đấy Bạn thấy
chưa thì Những cái ô nào ấy mà có năm là
trong 2016 đang 18 thì nói cho tô màu
đấy bây giờ ví dụ đây là 2017 mình sửa
thành 2019 nhá Đấy thì nó sẽ không tô
màu nữa Đang 2016 đó là mình sửa đây
2014 đấy đấy thì nó sẽ không tô màu nữa
đánh với đội đang là 2015 lấy cạ xóa đi
cọ sửa đây 2010 17 cảm thấy nó sẽ tô màu
rất là đẹp sang ví dụ thứ bảy là rẻ mình
sẽ Tô màu những ô theo khoảng thời gian
ở bên ngoài rất là dễ những cái ô nào mà
nó trong khoảng từ ngày đến ngày này thì
mình sẽ tô màu lên đấy Cái này cũng khá
là hay đấy Đấy cách ngày từ ngày đến
ngày mình sẽ là nhập từ bên ngoài vào
nhá Đấy thì đầu tiên mình sẽ xóa cái quy
luật cũ đi để mình hướng dẫn các bạn trả
lại từ đầu nhá các bạn sẽ Bôi đen này
cao đẳng giờ thì hôm mình sẽ bà con đi
xâm lược marketing kreide Đợi mình sẽ
chọn bên này thì đầu tiên là gì
ô tô đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà có định tô
màu đó các bạn sẽ vào thẻ hôm này các
bạn và con Lisa được for Mac tinh mình
sẽ là liu riu để đoạn phân tích ở dưới
này để mình sử dụng công thức nhắc lại
tức là mình cho tô màu trong khoảng đúng
không thì cậu sẽ bằng này đấy bạn có thể
diện bằng em nhé Em của mở ngoặc đấy Thì
cái ngày này là cái OVA 4 không các bạn
sẽ ở nhà cấp 4 1 2 3 lần Bà Rịa nhỏ hơn
rồi bằng viện bằng cái ngày đến ngày ở
đây đúng không phải nhá thì đến cái các
bạn sẽ rất là cái bốn này các bạn gấp 4
1 2 3 lần mà diện mà lớn hơn hoặc bằng
bằng cái ô từ ngày ở đây đấy bạn chú
nhắc cái ô B4 và C4 tức là từ ngày đến
ngày thì các bạn luôn cố định Họ đây các
bạn đấy B4 và C bố luôn cố định tại vì
mình sẽ định dạng cho cái ô dưới này vẫn
tham chiếu đến hai cái ô B4 và C4 đấy
các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc lại màn Tức là cái
hạ men này nó thỏa mãn thì bạn sẽ gì Các
bạn thấy pho mát đúng không vì sẽ là
Ừ dạo này chữ màu đỏ đúng không Và Thẻ
phim mình cho màu vàng chọn bấm ok ok
đấy Bạn thấy chứ Thì như vậy Những cái
Oh ở đây nó nằm trong khoảng này rồi thì
nó sẽ tô màu đây ví dụ mình sẽ từ 2010
10 đi nó enter đợi thì hai ô dưới này là
2015 sẽ được tô màu đúng không đây ví dụ
2018 mình đổi thành điện 20 30 đi thì
như vậy là diệt toàn bộ đã được tô màu
đây mình sẽ quay về ban đầu nhá nghĩ đó
là 2020 2018 đi đúng không ạ Ví dụ ở đây
nhá Đang là tôm mai anh 18 vòng Ví dụ
mình đổi thành 2019 đi đấy thì nó sẽ
không tô màu nữa Còn đây là 2016 mình
đổi thành 2009 đi thì nó sẽ không tô màu
nữa nó rất là hai ạ Ok sang ví dụ cuối
cùng là gì ạ Mình sẽ Tô màu những cái
sản phẩm mà hết hạ đấy Cái này cũng khá
là hay đấy Tức là mình cũng tô màu theo
cái cột sản phẩm và mình rất tô màu cả
cái
A và cái ngày hết hạn nhá Đấy thì giả sử
là gì ạ Đây là cái ô mà lại lấy ngày hôm
nay đợi thì hôm nay mình thực hành cái
video này là ngày 28 tháng 10 đúng không
Đây thì nó sẽ tùy thuộc vào cái ngày mà
bạn thực hành thì có thể nó sẽ là ngày
30 hay 31 tháng 10 gì đấy hoặc là sang
tháng 11 thì phụ thuộc vào cái này các
bạn thực hành nhá Đấy thì đây mình có
thông tin được thì mình có sản phẩm vào
ngày hết hạn rồi những cái trường hợp
nào Cái ngày hết hạn mà nó nhỏ hơn cái
ngày tôi đây tức là cái ngày hôm nay nó
qua cái này rồi thì nghĩa là cái sản
phẩm đã hết hạn đúng không còn những cái
ngày hết hạn nào ở đây mà nó lớn hơn cái
ngày hôm nay thì chắc là nó vẫn còn hạn
sử dụng đúng không Trong các ví dụ này
của mình đang toàn là nhỏ hơn cái ngày
hôm nay bây giờ mình sẽ sửa lại mít nhé
đây ví dụ đây là 25 tháng 11 đi đấy để
còn thấy chưa thì lúc này nó không tô
màu nữa đây là ví dụ tháng 12 đấy Đây là
nam việc đây là năm 2021 hạn thế đấy bây
giờ cái ngày hẹn ạ Bôi đen này các bạn
tăng C để copy cái đoạn sẽ tích vào ô
này các
thì các bạn tết Castle để mình sẽ tiết
ra Các bạn bấm ok đấy thì như vậy là gì
ạ Đây những cái ô nào mà dẹp hết hạn thì
nó cho tô màu cả hàng lên lại thì giả sử
Cái này của mình là như thế này bây giờ
bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu của mình
nhá Đấy mình sẽ xóa cái định dạng cũng
lên các bạn vào thẻ hôm các bạn vào
conditional formatting kludi các bạn sẽ
chọn ở trên này Bây giờ mình sẽ làm mới
nhé thì đầu tiên mình cho tô màu mỗi cái
cột sản phẩm thôi đúng không đấy thì đầu
tiên là thì các bạn sẽ bôi tôi đem cái
của sản phẩm là cái này rất là ngay Mặc
dù mình dựa vào cái này hết hạn nhưng mà
để tô màu cái cục sản phẩm thì mình sẽ
Bôi đen Cái cục sản phẩm nhá Đấy sau đó
bạn vào thẻ hôm các bạn và con this
lượng pho mát tinh khỏi gọi chọn cho
mình là nhẹ luôn thì họ sẽ tích vào cái
ô dưới cùng để mình sử dụng công thức
nha các bạn chất bằng bằng gì ạ bằng Nếu
Nhưng mà cái này ở đây tức là cái ôm C6
các bạn sẽ nhấn bố cho mình 1 2
à mà gì ạ Mà nhỏ hơn nhỏ hơn cái ngày
hôm nay lại của Cái ô thì đây là cái ô
hát hay này thì cái hai này phải cố định
tại vì mình sẽ áp dụng các định dạng này
cho cái ô dưới này Cho nên hay phải là
cố định Tức là nó ngon Cái ngày hôm nay
thì nghĩa là nó hết hạn rồi đúng không
Thì gọi cho format này Đấy cái thẻ phim
này mình sẽ tô màu màu vàng nhá Phone
này mình sẽ cho chữ động
ở Bà Rịa màu đỏ lên phải gọi cho ok ok
đấy Bạn thấy chứ như vậy sản phẩm 2 sản
phẩm 3 sản phẩm năm là gì là hết hạn rồi
đấy Cái ngày hết hạn là 15 tháng 4 mà
hôm nay là 28 tháng 10 rồi thế nào rồi
nhé Đây cũng thế Đây là hạn là mùng 4
tháng 8 mà đây là gì 28 tháng mưa đây
cũng vậy nhá 22 tháng 7 là hết hạn rồi
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ tô cả hàng thì nó
cũng giống như cái trên mình chỉ khác là
mình cho Model cả sản phẩm càng ngày hết
hạn đúng không các bạn vào thẻ hôm
conditional formatting lại gọi chọn cái
lu lại các bạn chọn cái cuối cùng để
mình làm công thức nhé các bạn sẽ bằng
với ạ Các bạn sẽ chọn cái ngày thế nào ở
đây là cái ô S6 là các bạn f412 lần đấy
thì như vậy là cố định kết của em này
đúng không Mà gì ạ Mà nhỏ hơn cái ô khác
hay này là cái ngày hôm nay thì bọn
format Nữa phần ở đây đúng không tô đậm
màu đỏ đi
tô màu đỏ và tô vàng Khá là đẹp đấy Mình
sẽ chọn cái này nhá tớ gọi cho bấm ok để
vẫn thế chứ lúc này nó sẽ tô màu cả cái
sản phẩm và ngắn hạn luôn rất là hai ạ
Ok như vậy mình xong cái phần hướng dẫn
định dạng có điều kiện của ngày hôm nay
nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ mở cái câu hỏi cho
cái bài tập về nhà nhé các bạn mở cái
file câu hỏi này lên thì trong cái câu
hỏi này mình sẽ làm ba cái ví dụ đấy thì
đầu tiên là gì ạ Cái khu vực phía Bắc
thì mới cho tô màu xanh này khu vực miền
Trung bị cho tô màu cam và khu miền Nam
mình sẽ tô màu này mình chiếc tô màu ở
cái cụt Cô Tô màu này nhá của giây nhá
Đấy con cái Cách thứ 2 là diện mình sẽ
tô màu theo cái phần trăm Hoàn thành đấy
thì giả sử các phần trong hoàn thành
mình sẽ lấy ở bên này các bạn Thúy nhá
trong cái bài số một này cách 1 này thì
cái phần trăm hoàn thành mình sẽ lấy cái
thực hiện cho kế hoạch đúng không con
cái Cách thứ hai là cái ví dụ ở đây mình
sẽ lấy cái phần trăm hoàn thành từ cái
cách 1 này
Ừ nhưng mà mình sẽ tô màu theo cái phần
trăm hoàn thành từ 0 đến 50 phần trăm
thì mình cho tô màu xanh 50 đến 80 tỉnh
màu cam và lớn hơn 80 thì màu xám đấy
lấy thịt trong cái cách ba này nó giống
như cách 2 nhưng mà gì nó sẽ hiện cả cái
giá trị lên đấy đấy là cái bài tập về
nhà cho các bạn nhá Ok mình cho đóng cái
vai rồi đấy Ok như vậy là mình đã kết
thúc bài học này Hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn
các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhỏ đăng kí
kênh để cập nhật video mới nhất của gà
cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng
học cách xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại
[âm nhạc]
ở